auditionné analyser la déclaration des
dix prévenus dans ce dossier de trafic
de cocaïne de transport d'argent entre
la martinique et l'hexagone
l essentiel de cette première journée
d'audience si certains prévenus
maintiennent leurs premières
déclarations d'autres communes agents
d'exploitation d'une compagnies
aériennes affectées au fret de lui
plusieurs versions il dit qu'il n'a pas
joué un rôle fondamental et apparemment
on s'est servi de lui des hommes
pratiquement inconnu de la justice
le 16 août 2016 une première saisie de
31 kg de cocaïne à l'aéroport d'orly
permet aux hommes de l'octris dentaire
et de martinique de procéder à
l'audition de plusieurs prévenus
c'est un dossier bon finalement assez
classique en deux
de transport de
de stupéfiants bien qu'il n'y ait qu'une
saisie effective dans ce dossier quand
même beaucoup de monde y est
c'est un dossier où la plupart des gens
ont des casiers judiciaires vierges et
puis finalement on peut penser que ce
qui donne de l'importance à ce dossier
c'est peut-être la présence d'un
policier qui a impliqué voilà tout
simplement ce fonctionnaire de la police
nationale de 43 ans qui a brisé sa
carrière est depuis le 26 août 2016
incarcéré au centre pénitentiaire de
ducos
il avoue qu'il s'est laissé griser par
le jeu notamment le poker endettés ils
tombent dans cet engrenage sont un
faciliter le passage des détenteurs de
cubi de cocaïne d'argent par une porte
de service afin d'éviter tout contrôle
comme ce policier
plusieurs protagonistes avouent qu'ils
se sont laissé piéger par l'appât du
gain
ce qu'on peut retenir et qui est
constant c'est que chacun a été happé
par ce système là chacun était dépassée
par ce système là et je crois que c'est
ce qu'il a voulu partager ce matin avec
le tribunal pour preuve si besoin
d'appuyer contrôle que ça ne trouve
vient pas d'une démarche personnelle
mais véritablement que dans ce cadre là
il a été il a mis le doigt il a été
appuyé par l'engrenage le besoin on est
dans une société de consommation où on
n'a pas suffisamment d'argent même
lorsqu'on travaille et on s'endette et
vous savez les mules ça se recrutent sur
le terreau des jambes et zone yeux
l'appât du gain certes mais l'infraction
est répréhensible
l'audience se poursuit demain à partir
de 14 heures